hey here's an interesting voicemail you
can call me at 2192 david p
here's a guy saying how can i be calling
for unity now
when i was against the things donald
trump did when he was elected this guy
misunderstands my position but let's
take a listen
yeah hi i got a question i'm listening
to your show today it's uh monday the
25th
and you're talking something about unity
and it's like
i don't understand um we were saying
unity four years ago
when trump was president i mean
uh i don't understand that you're saying
you want unity now but
back then you everything he did you were
against
no no no no i am not the ones demanding
unity i'm the one
saying anyone thinking there will be
unity doesn't understand what's going on
and so this is a very very important
thing i had i was not hypocritically
demanding unity
in 2016 and uh
or or ignoring it then
and then now calling for it back in 2016
i was clear listen trump won
and i'm going to oppose the things he
does if i think they should be opposed
joe biden now won and we know that we
aren't going to see
any unity from the right joe biden is
asking for unity
some republicans are asking for unity
even though for them the definition of
unity is biden
not doing anything different than donald
trump i'm not the one calling for unity
i'm the one pointing out it's not going
to happen so that that's
certainly a misunderstanding we've got a
great bonus show today
we will talk about control of the senate
we will talk about harriet tubman on the
20
build that is back in the news we will
talk about trump's second impeachment
trial
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinpakman.com